how did this all come about when did you
two become friends let's let's roll it
back a couple of years
and i've got a true hollywood story yeah
this is our true hollywood story how did
this start how did this friendship start
okay so i like i feel like annie and i
were at a place in comedy where we both
kind of knew who the other one was and i
like had heard she'd come to the comedy
store
and she got passed right away and i was
really excited to meet her because she's
just like young hot
funny comics i'm like ooh like i want to
see her boobs or something so i saw her
in the hallway disappointed you must
have been i saw her in the hallway and
like right away i just like locked eyes
with her and i i think i what did i i
think i pulled your shirt off i believe
you pulled my tits out or you pulled
yours out like i i remember feeling like
you were trying to
like shock me and i was like [ __ ] wrong
girl and like pulled my tits out too or
pulled yours out right yeah i just felt
like oh i know this girl is gonna be
down i can just tell from her energy
like there is no shocking her like i
just knew that i i could tell but we had
the same manager so we both had this
manager back in the day our first one of
our first daddies
hi hollywood daddy
um
sorry we fired
i just can't believe your name dropping
a person we fired
no it's fine it's fine it's fine
but he so
when i saw you at the comedy store
you're very obvious who you are because
he had sent me your your like real at
one point and then i watched a bunch of
your stuff and you're so little and your
name was little esther that it wasn't
like i was gonna forget who you were
your name or anything so i remember
going up to you and going
oh we have the same manager
and then you were great i mean the tits
were out immediately
it was fast friends yeah it was fast
friends and it was also fast enemies
because this story takes a turn
so kalyla it could be you one day
i can't wait for that day
but also i
i hope it's a long time from now yeah
well you know what i want to know is
what is your what are your early
memories of me because i also remember
clicking with you right away like seven
or eight years ago whatever it was when
i was do opening for bobby at the irvine
improv it was the first time i met you
and i just
i remember liking you right away knowing
not to be too too aggressive but and
then i and then
imagine thinking when you meet someone
of like what the move is
just imagine being like i don't want to
come on too much of this or that oh
she's look at her just kind of planning
at all
but then i learned you were a nurse so
you were so i'm like oh she's
what
just the idea that i just imagine you
finding out she was a nurse and like
sweet now i can complain to her about
all my ailments and that's been our
entire friendship
that was kind of our beginning too
and then when i was in on a tour in
australia new zealand and i got sick i
just remember i was texting with you
every day and you were helping me and i
was like i just was like oh me and kyle
are like
we're in this forever
wait but i need to know what is your
first memory of me like do you have any
yeah the first the first thing you said
to me you didn't introduce yourself you
didn't say who you were i i went into
the green room and you're like do you
want to see my boobs
do you remember that you have one move
but you because you're calculated you
knew to with her to ask and with me you
just assaulted me
but you didn't ask to see mine in return
but i know i was trying i was angling
for it that was my tactic did i get to
see your boobs are you gonna come out in
the first episode are we gonna like
tease it for a while um i don't think
you've ever i i now regret never showing
you my fake boobs because you don't have
any reference for what they look like
before and what
how disastrous they look now there's no
way they look disastrous
consider this
i had double d's
smashed into
little a cups
there is some
stretch there is stretch but i guess
it's probably not bad but i guess
because i only had them for two years
um the skin kind of like held up its
integrity do you want to
show me in the back room and when i can
come back and say what i think like why
does it have to be a back room like it's
so creepy it can't be a front room it
has to be a back room oh you're so
that's how esther and i met were you
threatened by me at all were you like oh
keep her away from my man
what did you like me did you what did
you think i just thought that you were
as close of a version to bobby
as i'd ever met because i'd met other
comics at that point and i was like huh
bobby sort of like stands in his own
lane he is just this he is just who he
is until i met you i was like oh they're
the same kind they're cut from the same
cloth so you thought she's calling you
fat
so so you thought i was a lot like your
boyfriend yes okay
and so i felt very what's the opposite
of the most threatened
secure very very i wouldn't even say
secure i just felt very um
okay with your existence in the green
room thank you and immediately i found
you really funny really yeah cause i saw
your stuff oh she's look she's she saw
yourself
that's really that was she riffing i
can't imagine it was her jokes
annie on the other hand i was super
intimidated by it well when did we first
meet i remember seeing you at the comedy
show but i don't know if we met maybe we
never got introduced until we did tiger
belly okay properly but i had seen you
there maybe twice and i remember you
wearing all black with like a black
leather jacket yeah
your skin was like snatched to the
heavens your eyes had a really perfect
like upturned angle you had to really
like you had a lot of bass in your voice
and i was like oh gosh i need to stay
away
and this is this is a slow this is gonna
this is gonna happen slowly and
organically i can't force it isn't that
interesting her first instinct was stay
away
isn't it interesting her first instinct
was you remind me of my
asian boyfriend
and um so yeah i remember thinking holy
[ __ ] is she i remember asking bobby i
was like is she uh just a super hot girl
who's someone's girlfriend or is she a
comic because i couldn't imagine i was
like
if i booked the club a super hot girl
this is so fun you know i always thought
i was ugly until recently bobby has um
has a gift for all of us for chinese new
year oh
oh my god oh wow
thank you that's some durian fruit what
yeah
oh fancy durian fruit has it ever been
living it looks like it was something
that was the live ones
yeah it was living i'd get killed
i cut myself right here cutting it come
here babe come to me come to me and uh
have you had durian no come on come on
between
here let me hold this uh-huh
tell us what you have said well this
right here is durian
[Laughter]
this right here is durian fruit and um
yeah yeah yeah let's just assume a mango
was in vegas right he had no money
and he prostituted himself to get a
ticket back home i feel like a mango is
a girl bobby obviously right and um
it's basically if you know a mango um
could take a [ __ ]
that's what it is do you like it no i
[ __ ] hate it and it's why do you have
it
no
oh yeah you're gonna eat it so well
listen all right once a year my people
have a new year
okay so do my people exactly right
and so um
for me it's like it's killing you oh
don't touch me well i'm describing okay
[Laughter]
so um once a year my people um we
celebrate by eating a durian fruit and
um white people um are very um what much
welcome
and um of course smell it if you if you
can't i smell it from here it's gonna
smell it from closer oh you know i'll
eat it i'm down
i want to watch annie eat it no esther
you have to do it looks like chicken
mango but then it goes foul it goes into
bad foot really soon look
okay so i annie you eat it oh it looks
like mustard oh no we need it we need
everybody to take a taste you know yeah
with your hands yeah grab something
my head looks like i feel like army
hammer this is like very fleshy
all right
all right it smells
it smells like fermented yeah it smells
fermented eating it
look i'm from the philippines this is my
fruit and even i can't eat it but i'm
gonna do it today she's eating it tastes
delicious
of course to you annie i like it you do
yeah you spring your hand for
look what i i like
because of the [ __ ] durian [ __ ]
i cut my [ __ ] up
oh i want another one yeah yeah i don't
know just just take this apart it's the
gizzard
the kids are not part of it
smells so bad give me more i want more
i'm spoiled a little brown it's like
garlicky
no eat it
don't smell it just eat it it smells
like [ __ ] garbage
garlic
[ __ ] eat it you eat garlic on your
[ __ ] sugar fish [ __ ] your little bat
eat the whole thing eat it put it in
your mouth and swallow it now [ __ ] it
bro
it tastes like onion i don't like it
bobby i don't care it's my [ __ ]
people all right hey give me more let me
have something over here it tastes like
a [ __ ] like slime
you know you're a super smeller esther
and it is pretty super smaller it's
pretty um
way more than that babe i'm sorry
babe listen to me
i'm going double
oh i'm gonna throw up
the taste does stay with you for a while
then
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is what comes out of joy diaz's
dick
i'm not doing well
i'm doing great
[Music]
babe you got to take it away i can't
deal with it all right i'll take it take
it away all right take it away
no no not near me
guys i genuinely liked him
so look at my face i'm not completely i
i like understand that you guys don't
have this experience i've hated it since
i was a kid who the [ __ ]
wanted to do that it was my idea and it
was it backfired let me take it outside
eat another trunk
if you honestly sweetie
i knew annie would like it i [ __ ]
knew it
i genuinely thought you were gonna vomit
on the camera no i genuinely thought
that i was down for this because i'm
like this is from my country right
i should be
i should have a predisposition to liking
it and i know that i hated it growing up
but i just thought okay like i'm an
adult now i can eat
and i can eat anything by the way like i
eat like
i eat anus
i cannot eat a durian for the rest of my
life that almost like you were really
hurting i was
i'll never recover i'll never be the
same i would rather eat bobby's anus
i do have a feeling they all taste very
similar
i you know what they don't
bobby's anus
does
is infinitely infinitely less putrid
so
that was our episode i do want to take
your mask off i cannot take my mask off
because the [ __ ]
maybe that's why i liked it it smells a
lot and tasted like my hoagie armpits
um but you guys thanks for listening
and what do we say just subscribe smash
smash the likes comment below share
about it on your social tell your
friends we'll repost you on our blood
bath girls instagram bloodbath girls
follow us on the gram
and
we'll be back with more disgusting
it really was i mean you did handle it
worse as someone that has grown up with
it and that's why i'm so sorely
disappointed in myself is like i know
for sure esther's gonna go down for this
one and and she didn't she actually
stood proud well i can't believe i even
licked it like i was it was a hard no
but bobby was [ __ ] screaming at me
and scaring me i'm gonna order some i'm
gonna get something you know what you
might try durian candy it's not as
strong
leave me out of it yeah see you guys
guys please follow us on instagram or
something i want to apologize for esther
can i want to change the subject two
weeks ago i went home
to visit my family and i
got a text from a guy that i was really
really close friends with in high school
like we you know my senior year we just
like we hung out all the time whatever
we were just really good friends
and
he was like hey i'm in skokie too do you
want to hang out so i went to his house
he went for a walk and he's like i want
to tell you something and i'm like what
he's like i had a crush on you all of
high school
and i was like what like it just changed
he took you you guys went out for him
just to say this like he had it in his
head too i'm not sure get it off his
chest
i i don't know
back a little
so
this like changed my i feel like this
changed everything for me because i'm
like whoa like a guy liked me like i
just never felt like guys were into me
and then he reminded me of something
that i completely forgot
he did finger me once
and he told me
that when he was fingering me he started
kissing me
and i asked him to stop kissing me and
to just said just finger me it's a boss
move babe and i was like i can't believe
i did that that's so like prostitute
level but i completely blocked it yeah
that is boss level i think maybe you're
right because kissing is so intimate to
me
that it's like if i am strictly wanting
something sexual from you there's a good
chance we'll never even kiss yeah i
don't want to see your [ __ ] face get
down there do the thing if i don't want
to kiss you i can't do anything with you
well i think it by the way if it was a
reverse and the guy was like don't kiss
me and just jerk you you would say i
know i will i think that'd be you'd say
i understand
but anyways i feel like i like left this
weird imprint on him and now like
because in high school at this like
important time i said like don't kiss me
yeah that that could be traumatic
i understand that
yeah when you're like when you're just
first starting getting sexual and then
someone says something i didn't get
chest hair until like i didn't have body
hair really and then i turned 18 and
then it just
and i went to my my first girlfriend
i went to her dorm and the guys or girls
are here guys are here same floor so i
went i showered over here and then i
walked across to her place i'm so lost
and bored with a towel around my my
lower half but
i had chest hair and my girlfriend at
the time was embarrassed
she goes cover your chest
and i
i
for i got so much laser hair removal you
did but hairy chest not in my chest but
like here and for like a decade because
i would
and it wasn't until years and years
later i used to do a bit about i talked
about how when i saw hugh jackman as
wolverine and i thought he looks great
for years i was so embarrassed to take
my shirt off oh my god there was this
guy um that i happened to cross on my
last trip on vacation to cross i
happened to um we happened to collide
our paths crossed and he had his shirt
off
and he had a patch of hair in the back
of his neck like further up on his back
and i didn't know this about myself but
i
was immediately attracted like i thought
holy [ __ ] i don't know what it is but
i want to touch it the hair the hair on
the top of his neck it was like the soul
patch and it was so [ __ ] hot esther
so i say guys if you're insecure about
your body hair hold out you're gonna
find some freak like me who's going to
really really love it including your
chest hair can we see your nose sure no
i'm not even embarrassed about my chest
here anymore as much as i am about how
like
skinny and out of shape and unathletic i
love we can't see
i don't want to
i see lingerie up show us i don't
i don't really
i don't really show us what it is
no it's pale wow you're you're insecure
it's okay yeah i know
i'm sure you do
you fat piece of [ __ ]
could you edit out
uh
that out because you're not supposed to
say stuff about weight because
everyone's beautiful but the truth is
heavy people are beautiful if there's
some you know but there's just nothing
nothing about you you know
you're just a pawn that
could only move one space on the first
turn
[Music]
sometimes i need so much help i have a
headache do you know what i mean yeah i
just want some help i want it now
i don't want to have to find a new
therapist and make sure they're in my
network show up find parking all that
stuff and that's why i am
so grateful in this beautiful new year
for better health check out
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday betterhelp will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
connect in a safe and private online
environment it's so convenient you can
start communicating in just under 48
hours we love that you can send a
message to your counselor any time and
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions all without ever
having to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed some weeks i don't
want to see my therapist's face
that phone option really is great i can
roll around in bed look crusty and you
know look crusty
um be half naked
parking driving traffic therapist
um anything you share is confidential is
convenient professional and affordable
we want you to start living a happier
life today like we all have with better
help and as a listener you'll get 10 off
your first month by visiting our sponsor
at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over one million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health again that's
betterhelphelp.com
trash tuesday you know what i'm over
what i'm over shopping at the mall it's
so annoying i do like them all but let's
be real i'm going for the pretzels
you know how you have um you make
impulse buys and now it doesn't work out
for you and you have to go return it
then you walk your ass to the mall i
mean especially after all that holiday
shopping i'm over it there was no
parking anywhere nightmare i'm so glad
for freestyle stitch fixed it's weird
stitch fix freestyle is a shop that is
built just for you stitch fix freestyle
is your trusted style destination where
you can discover and instantly buy
curated items based on your style likes
and lifestyle with styles from workouts
to work wear for lounging around the
house or for a night out stitch fix
freestyle has clothes for any occasions
get started today by filling out your
style quiz at stitchfix.com
tuesday that's
stitchfix.com tuesday to try stitch fix
freestyle stitchfix.com
tuesday
do you get hard easily if you're with
your girlfriend or like a a lover yeah i
don't i don't i i don't i don't think i
have it sounds like erectile dysfunction
it sounds like you do though i don't i'm
saying i don't i'm not ruling it out it
but it's never it's it's not an issue
like there's no
issue i i can't how do you know because
there hasn't been many times there's
been a few but there's been many times
in my life where i'm like oh [ __ ] i
can't have sex
it's just that i don't want to
so the the situation that i was talking
about before where is the most
uncomfortable is if you find yourself
making out you're rubbing genitalia but
i
i don't want to be doing this
i don't want to be doing any of this
show
the show right now
uh that was the that was a yeah that's
what i was implying but i don't mean
that you know the first night that i
because i used to date a comedian tony
inch cliff and the first night we hung
out we had like you know what you were
saying what was just doing was doing
show me your sketches because you didn't
say anything in the quotes oh what was i
doing but like dry sex like humping well
isn't dry sex you call it sex is dry sex
but with doing you dry sex sounds like
it's some it sounds like a sex okay
whatever we were dry sexing you know oh
yeah i'm bad at the quotes you're right
you caught me
so
it's dry humping we were dry humping the
first night we hung out
and he came in his pants oh my god isn't
that amazing i do you know how
good that would make me feel i told you
this some guy came on my kneecap and
i've never felt like a bigger boss in my
life he was like oh your legs and you
grabbed my legs and you nutted on my
kneecap wait what i was like
wait what do you mean i must be some
kind of [ __ ] specimen do you really
think it was you and not the fact that
he comes like that
you think i can never come but all of a
sudden i came on her knee here's the
thing rick i don't like guys that last
long and that's a fact same yeah i i
well it's long i mean you want five
eight minutes right more than a maximum
eight to ten yeah and i feel like that's
already him really trying to like think
of his grandma on baseball and other
things is that a thing people really do
i don't know but do you know
if you're trying to last long you just
change positions
why
because then you get it's like when
you're working out you take a rest
hey like i'm sure i don't know if anyone
ever [ __ ] you face forward but like
if you're behind maybe you would say
here get on my back and face i'll get my
back face that way or something
i feel like you should ring your bells
i i sometimes
feel bad insulting you because it feels
like i'm being mean to dave oh that's
true because that oh dave's like oh what
are you saying like my standards are
such and such you're disrespecting his
woman
well i don't feel yeah yes that's not
the issue i feel like it's disrespecting
his tastes and he's had obviously such
great taste he's a very creative smart
you know you can pivot you know just
you could go after me
esther could use a break go after you
for what i don't know if you feel like
let me see if i can make fun of your
tits take off your bro this is a paid
service
subscribe and you can see it sure well
hey we'll put this part on patreon hold
on a second sir go ahead
i really have not put you on around in
several days you don't wear the other
day can i smell it
yes it's not good i don't want to get up
because i'm wearing a thong do it
i don't want to get up because she just
[ __ ] her pants
i was hoping for a bigger laugh and made
me feel immature
it's the same as the blood bath girls we
can't like look at what they're doing
what what they all want is our attention
and us talking about them so the blood
death girls are now trying i don't know
what they're trying to do to me or
whatever i'm never watching it i don't
care anyone that watches whatever their
[ __ ] [ __ ] video is and and agrees
with them please oh unfollow everything
i've ever done get the [ __ ] away from me
i literally am here to
[ __ ] get over myself be good make
people feel good make people laugh if
you don't want to get on board with that
get the [ __ ] away from me like i will
not be controlled i never have been i
never will be it's like [ __ ] off by the
way the best point ever made was about
the name bloodbath when it's friends
making fun of each other and it's a
little bit of a period joke is cute
bloodbath when it's about the victims of
a [ __ ] crime
one of the comments they said about us
was like serial killers are better than
us we're worse than serial killers
because we don't apologize to the
victims by the way there's nothing to
apologize to and the serial killers are
not okay they're never okay you are
misogynists you're misogynist you hate
women you pray and you try to make money
off of the death of innocent [ __ ]
women so how about that how about that
do you want us to [ __ ] release that
[ __ ] yeah do you want people to know
that about you drop that [ __ ]
off we're showing girls that they can be
themselves get over their [ __ ] trauma
love each other be supportive and speak
their own [ __ ] mind in a world where
men tell us what to [ __ ] say all the
time and we have to conform we don't
[ __ ] do that we talk about diarrhea
period blood and we [ __ ] eat gross
[ __ ] all right
[ __ ] you like during and we're like
we're horrible we both we never bullied
you once we took the name down we just
were trying to be nice to you and you
wanted more you wanted merch money you
wanted attention all you want is money
clout and to look like victims well
you're not [ __ ] victims but you know
who are the girls you exploit for your
[ __ ] show that has 40 followers so
enjoy your shitty little career
and you'll never get a hundred thousand
[ __ ] dollars from us if you would ask
for ten by the way you might have gotten
yeah
mama has spoken it's like enough like
what what do we want our followers to do
not be themselves and scared and and
victims of their we were all [ __ ]
molested in every hole except esther but
her time will come
maybe during this episode i had some
things yeah i did a couple things that's
true
for some reason she hides them
i think that you hit the nail on the
head and i think that ultimately
we've not call it what it was which has
they've been bullies you're you're
bullying us you're trying to extort us
we know our power and that's why we
don't talk about you because you will be
destroyed by our fans we don't want them
to feel bad we don't want them to go
against you we want to just move on with
the shittiest name ever kalila picked it
i didn't enjoy it
george does coke though so we'll give
him a pass he's a drug
addict and he's drugged do you guys want
to hear two girls talk about the same
murders you've heard everyone else talk
about yeah who are calling us bullies
out of nowhere that we've literally been
protecting for months and months and
months do you hate our new name so do we
everyone [ __ ] does we loved our name
it made sense we could have coexisted
with them we actually were going to have
them be our true crime correspondents
but they went around and told everyone
we were thieves and liars and said we
were doing things we never did they are
unsafe
i don't negotiate with terrorists
yes so go watch their show if you like
it and resonate with it please give them
your money give me your attention please
they need it seems like they really want
to build an empire go follow them do
whatever do it do it do it on the
charities
because even after we change the name
they still took it down vengefully they
they literally gave us more [ __ ] even
after we changed the name after we
changed the name and it's like i don't
even want to be mad because i shouldn't
let anyone make me mad but it's like
it's so [ __ ] frustrating we're biting
our tongues trying to help and protect
them and they can't stop and we've been
harassed and bullied harassed and
bullied everybody wanted a private
apology from esther because they made up
a situation in their head where they
thought esther was speaking directly to
them that's where you feel that's like
stalking her
someone out there thinks you're speaking
to them that like is what made me feel
unsafe that's where i'm
making up something in your head that
i'm i'm threatening you or i think the
line that they were upset about was like
one and like one of our first podcasts
which we filmed months before we even
they even acknowledged us
was you said um like where's the
bloodbath girls let it be known like and
and they let the cor it's been a
bloodbath let the courts see
me
because it's bloodbath because we're
friends that [ __ ] with each other do you
understand it has nothing to do with you
listen angels go for your life get over
yourselves your life will be better okay
i work on this myself too okay i'm not
saying i'm perfect and i want i want you
to be successful and but your mindset is
not correct okay your mindset is
paranoid and it's not it is not
it's not where we're coming from and you
want an apology i'm sorry i'll say i
don't know what the [ __ ] i'm apologizing
for but i'm sorry no i'm getting
emotional because i do feel like i i i
think that anyone can relate to this
like there's something in your life that
you have to just keep a smile on your
face and you can't let people know
what's going on behind the scenes but
like since the day we started this
podcast this has been going on and we
never talk about it because like like
what women usually do we just put a
smile on our faces and like keep it
going and i
i'm just there's something emotionally
cathartic i think that's what it is
esther is that we genuinely don't want
to hurt anyone even like this is a
comedy show yeah like we've never set
out to hurt anyone's feelings step on
anyone's toes this was our whole our
home project between three friends we
came up with a a name from the english
dictionary that we liked that was once a
that was based on the band that is like
you know and and
what we set out to do was just something
light and funny and really positive and
what has transpired and helping women
helping such a bummer
and the fact that we've had to just take
the high road and play nice
and pretend like nothing's happening is
you're right it's it's it's been a
[ __ ] frustrating process and did i
not do we not have a conversation where
he's like you know what we should just
do a thing and try to be as nice as
possible and every time we're about to
do that they send another threatening
[ __ ] email some threat about
something or we've done this or we
changed the name on purpose like
stop watching true crime stop it
you're paranoid stop well okay
got a puppy
got a puppy go look at the trees it's
beautiful out it's beautiful out what
about the weeks or months that like
after we changed the name because we
were being threatened like all a lot of
our listeners were upset and they they
were like oh i don't want to listen
anymore because you changed your name
and we're just sitting here like we
didn't want to change our name like we
were being harassed and by the way i
didn't tell anyone
there was no taking of a name we didn't
know who you were literally
you literally have a i'm not even trying
to be rude you have a small following
it's very very small it's very small you
know what we're doing we're actually
business women that are getting together
to write due to a podcast that resonates
with young girls that makes them happy
do you know what happens when i do my
shows now my live shows girls come up
crying that they feel so much better
about being molested and what's happened
to them because we talk openly about it
so keep shutting us down we're so mean
to women we're so mean to them and then
go oh is there another girl that got
murdered innocently that you want to
bathe in their blood
like what are you talking about and did
we ever once say we don't want you to
have the name do we ever care did have
anything to do we didn't know you
existed until we already had launched
and filmed the first few episodes so
sorry we came up with the name before
you existed i don't know what you're
talking about there's no thievery no
one's taking from you and it didn't take
anything from you all it did was get you
more attention yeah and honestly we're
happy to share that attention yeah it's
like look like
whatever
trickle-down followers that you get out
of this
happy to have you see how happy to see
you have them we were gonna have you be
correspondents but we you know we don't
have people that call us liars and
thieves and make up stories about us and
bully us that's who we don't have yeah
i'm sorry this has been honestly my
favorite episode
because and i and i really apologize for
like my i shouldn't be this heated
because i don't it's anger's not the
thing it's just it's exactly what
esther's saying it's like we've been
holding it yeah yeah and like i
literally like on the verge of tears
like since you started talking about the
asian stuff like i'm just so
it's such a shitty feeling to like hold
something in and be be harassed and be
scared and like i don't know it's just
and be told you're bad when your
intentions were never like never bad at
all right i don't even know what to say
like i don't i don't know what to say
i'm just like glad we're talking about
this it's like therapeutic because this
has just been really shitty and i'm
grateful that we have the show and that
we [ __ ] are we're a huge success yeah
and guess what yes we are we're huge no
matter no matter what you're doing
she's the only one that exercises
whether worf whether this is blood bath
trash juice they slug town annie esther
kalila show it's whatever we imbue it
with right it's like our followers our
fans we love them so dearly they've
latched we've latched back it's like
this
mutualistic love and no matter what we
are no matter what name we have we're
going to do well it also doesn't matter
it's like you can have the name we don't
care we've done stop harassing us guys
it's like we've given you a b c d and e
everything just leave us the [ __ ] along
you got our itunes taken down that's
more people that could have been
inspired and felt good about themselves
that can't have that now also when there
was a third podcast bloodbath
like they bully the [ __ ] out of those
they did
and it's like dude like it's just how
many bad friends are there there's like
five yeah yeah how many like hey baby
this exists i used to do a thing called
sausage party presents with me and my
friend abby was called sausage party it
was we would take hot dogs and we would
recreate scenes with it and we would
make original content and then i saw my
friend caper lant on the subway she was
oh my god congrats on the movie i go
what are you what are you talking about
she goes oh you're doing that movie with
seth seth uh
party and i went
nope that's unfortunate oh well you move
on you make something new you keep
moving forward nothing about our show
gets in the way of your show in any way
yeah i think that if you spent all of
this energy and legal fees into actually
creating legitimate content
you would build an empire but if you're
continually continually obsessing and
using that energy to go after girls that
are just trying to do a home project
um
it's gonna it's
it's gonna backfire esther how many
alone togethers were there in the world
uh a lot well look it became like the
slogan for covid 19. yeah look at that
coven stone and there was another one we
should still call it coverto zester an
apology clove has been looking at you
through the camera and yelling at you
yeah it's just so it's this is a it was
a it's been a really weird situation
that i just didn't see coming for myself
or for us what i found the funniest
though is they really had it up for you
poor little babies i mean that made me
feel scared like i
you know i've had stalkers and stuff
like i uh
there's protocol for that like yeah i
you know
had to
do some things to make sure you know i i
just don't know
who these people are when they start
talking you like they know you i don't
know it's just this whole thing is it's
really shitty and i feel like people
all all day every day there are people
out there in their own workplaces where
they have to grin and smile through
something where they're being harassed
or like threatened
um and it just is so shitty and i wish
there was something that we could do and
maybe even just sharing about it is
helpful but it's i don't know it's just
it's like i just feel really emotional
like i can't articulate and yeah i don't
know like i just i'm so grateful that
annie is here to like
be our mouthpiece yeah so you're going
to like say what i think we've all been
feeling and afraid to say all of this to
say by the way
stop complaining about the name change
we're going to change it into something
else we're like an art exhibit
maybe we should just keep it honestly
maybe we should just keep it the name
doesn't matter you guys are what matter
the three of us i look my i wanted to
pitch to take the h out and just be
blood bats
that's great we should do bad baths
bleed baths i want slug bath slug bath
oh yeah slug bath slug bath is cute
bath girls i had no i [ __ ] all over
esther and her mother
and now i didn't know she's been being
harassed online i want to get on track
but i'm also glad we feel so how about
this we hop off the horse and we switch
gears guys like we're very good at you
can call bobby and show him your tattoo
yes yeah i'm scared yeah what are you
scared about well maybe he's on set but
let's try i just feel like he's gonna be
like that's weird
like that's he's like well he's worried
about people saying that's weird when
they look at you
oh santino's calling me [ __ ] oh pick it
up yeah you know i called and i was just
trying to i was originally trying to
leave you a voice message singing happy
birthday to you and uh
um an old white guy voice but i think
you ruined it
well here let me hang up you can try
again old guys we're on the podcast
right now okay bye
okay bye
it's bobby it's bobby hi sweetie what's
up babe
esther wants to show you something
esther sent him the picture right now
okay what's the picture of what esther's
birthday present to me you will not
believe it i like your nails clipping on
me i'm really scared you want to see it
yeah text it to me
okay just sounds exciting stay on the
phone she's texting it to you right now
is she [ __ ]
crazy
is she dumb
is she dumb and crazy what is wrong with
that girl
i can't believe you caught our girl
she was dropped
by many agents actually
what does drops mean but as a baby in
your head yeah
no they never held him whatever you want
to say
anyway why did she is that real it's
real
well you're going to have to [ __ ] get
her an astropop tattoo
now i have to do it yeah yeah on your
neck
[Laughter]
right over adam's apple
all right babe i love you
that's so funny
okay here's andrew's um white man happy
birthday to you
[Music]
happy birthday
filipino
[Music]
that's pretty good it's pavarotti i
loved that that was
gorgeous
you can still sense the anger that deep
down anger he has as a gender
you guys i'm not kidding i usually don't
believe in a lot of products that say oh
you know your hair will grow back
thicker fuller but neutral actually
works and i can attest to this when i
turned 30 my hair started thin really
badly when i got off birth control even
worse
and within a span of like three four
months with a little bit of patience and
taking these pills as adjusted my hair
started to really really grow back it's
really helped me with when i wear the
clip-ins they're so heavy that it gives
me like little patches little bald
patches and like a domination under here
but the neutral folds help me grow back
you guys so nice 30 million women are
impacted by weakened or thinning hair
and if you're among them you are not
alone because you have us and know that
there's a solution that you can trust
that will actually deliver results
thousands of women have taken back
control of their hair with neutrophil
with many users raving that the
supplement not only transformed their
hair but restored their confidence too
and neutral offers two targeted formulas
for women that are clinically shown to
improve hair growth and thickness with
less shedding through all stages of life
in a clinical study eighty-six percent
of women reported improved hair growth
after six months more than fifteen
hundred top doctors recommend neutrophil
as an effective and high quality
solution for healthier hair i've also
bought it for dave and for carlos like
guys
they have it for guys too yes they have
a line for me
started it yet
you can throw thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrafull.com
trash to save 15 off your first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it is only available to us
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order get fifteen
dollars off at nutrafl.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l dot com slash trash you
guys we don't mind hair on a man
we don't mind a beard we don't mind hair
down there we just need to know that you
are grooming it well that you care and
that you care show us that you care by
just trying down there it's hot to groom
and it also does get hot down there and
let's just let it air out a little bit
more by
using some manscape that's why we love
manscaped manscape created the ultimate
groin and body trimmer for focusing on
creating a comfortable grooming
experience their fourth generation
trimmer features a cutting-edge ceramic
blade to reduce grooming accidents
say goodbye to beard hair around the
sink because the trimmer is waterproof
time to get him to shave in the shower
and while he's in there make sure he has
a new ultra premium body wash from
manscape to leave him feeling and
smelling good
their body wash is the perfect addition
to his self-care routine it's also
infused with aloe vera and sea salt to
keep skin feeling clean nice and
moisturized and the perfect way to leave
him feeling confident once he gets out
of the shower is with the manscaped
refined cologne it seriously leaves him
smelling amazing and features their same
signature scent as in all manscaped
formulas the perfect complement to a
self-care collection with manscaped
he'll look and smell like a new man use
the code trash for 20 off plus free
shipping at manscape.com
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code trash at manscape.com that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscaped.com and
use code trash upgrade his 2022
self-care routine with manscaped girl
would come over why can't you go to her
because i'm
the alpha
i'm a real alpha
a real alpha male
i don't know i just a girl comes over
it's easier for all parties yeah for you
yeah okay keep going but i have i mean
there's got to be a transaction right i
mean she has to be getting something
from me that's why i show her my
sketches
so then she'll come over
and um no
i'm comfortable i'm dressed comfortable
um they're like oh she you know she's
thinking
whoa i put on silly ears
some lipstick
put on a reservoir for my nice set of
tits
and all i had to do was show up and be
who i really am
so now she feels less than you because
she had to try hard no now she feels
more comfortable to be herself around me
that makes me feel more comfortable that
if i have an issue with like uh
performance anxiety
then i could be like well hold on let's
just you know watch something is that
something you actually have yeah
performance anxiety for sex or anything
i'm performing including sex yeah do you
have a sad penis no happiest part of my
body
i have a sad
perspective like do you just do you rate
yourself after do you like rank it
compared to other times you've had sex
like what's no no it's just it's uh
i i get i would get scared
that
i don't like have i i never wanted to
have sex right away um it wasn't like we
gotta you know meet each other's
families but on a first date or a second
i didn't want to have sex but i have
this thing built in where i feel like if
i don't have sex with her then she's
gonna think i'm a loser so i felt like
this need to have sex and that made that
would make me always feel uncomfortable
so if i got to the place where it's like
let's not have sex now
let's put on some sweatpants watch some
of my old videos
like the pilot that we did
and then it's like oh you know what hey
look
daddy's hard
okay
daddy's hard it's one way of daddy
playing okay but okay so now we'll have
sex or we don't have to but i can the
door's been unlocked i need the door to
be on i can't get hard until
somebody says that you announce it like
that daddy's hard it depends on the
energy no i've never said that like that
you know uh-huh
i'm into that you are i mean just i've
turned a corner esther what i like is is
really strange these days
you know what i'll say i'll say this
what i need
is
like because you're okay you're saying
like you kind of have to get you have to
watch your own sketches that's a joke
that's a joke that's a joke
that's a joke i don't think it was i
think you're realizing it after the fact
that you need to are you busting my
balls are you really are you that
far removed from bits that you think i
have girls come over and they watch that
guy in his friend sketches from 2010
where i'm pretending i'm in snl
that guy and his friend
in
snl no i don't have them watch my
sketches well i was going to say because
you made it seem like you kind of are
nervous to get and you can't really
you're not sure you're going to get it
up i'm i'm sc i'm i'm scared of the
obligation the assumption so i need to
get it across quickly and i would say
this like hey listen i
am probably going to be too scared to
have sex and if that's what you think is
going to be happening tonight we can't
do that tonight
okay let's do this
we're on a date i'm at your house
right and say change and wash your hands
say what you just said like so you just
said to me it would be before you got to
my house so you just said to me
really yeah before you come because when
a girl comes over there's the assumption
of oh something's going on and maybe
maybe if dad is hard but i don't know
so i'm just being fine i'm being fun i'm
being fine i don't i'm come on i'm being
i'm being fine i'm being fine i'm being
fine i'm being fine bobby lee
but
before so i'm saying hey listen you're
coming over i don't know what your
expectations are so let me help us get
on the same page
um i'm probably not gonna want to have
sex i'm not saying nothing's gonna
happen i don't know but like just know
like you would you be comfortable coming
over maybe we'll make out or maybe we'll
watch something maybe nothing maybe
something you would say this before they
get over there yeah god rick that's just
a whole lot of information yeah yeah
yeah
it's kind of walking through someone's
door
i don't want to be i
how do i say this with class it's safe i
mean i would feel safe walking in like i
know exactly what's going to go down
unless it's a trick but
if it's a trick hey we're not going to
have sex but then i have found that that
it wasn't my intention but i have found
that that
that was good
but still
no it wasn't a trick
it wasn't a trick so okay so let's say
i'm at your house
yeah and
you're like we don't let's say you tell
me in person like i don't have sex and
i'm like well i don't i didn't say i
wanted to either okay
i oh i don't date defensive people like
you
i i i i don't i don't enjoy people's
company when they're projecting that
when i'm talking my truth what would you
like the girl to say when you if you're
like
i'm gonna answer you and you're gonna
say gross okay here's what i want her to
say whatever
her truth is whatever she's feeling
because if she says this to me
hypothetically i love you you're the
most beautiful girl i've ever made
if she said i mean i get that we don't
have to have sex but i'm probably gonna
[ __ ] you and if you're nervous i'll suck
your dick while you're soft we'll figure
it out i'll make it come soft i'll
probably go like this come over
that's fine i just want you to know that
i might not be able to get hard until we
get to know each other a little but if
you're okay with that
that would probably get me hard so it
sounds like you have a hard time getting
hard i have yeah if daddy maybe daddy's
not so hard daddy is not hard i i i i
yeah i can't get hard unless i'm unless
i'm interested in the person i'm the
same way i can quiet wet until there's a
mental connection yeah but why do you
have them over if you're not interested
because it's because i'm i'm truthfully
not having them over to sleep with me i
don't love leaving the house do you like
making out do you like just making out
and like rubbing genitals love i love
all of it i love i love it all but i i
don't know i don't leave the house much
this is my date this is our date if
you're into going out on a date with me
where the date is you come over watch
some sketches and we do whatever i know
then come on it's not true i know it's
true i know guys like him they make you
watch their [ __ ] that they made
i'm gonna start doing that with bobby
just make him watch
these episodes
it's a joke
let me let me play put let me sprinkle
it in so i'm not just a [ __ ] snooze
fest who relies on her star power to get
the box
[ __ ] me i did it once for like a show
are you come on in
come babe and band underwear bobby let's
see her underneath i'm so sorry come on
in bobby my underwear i just woke up
come here babe quickly
quickly i swear to [ __ ] i forgot oh
you look so cute i know you thank you
but just get in front of the camera
enough that cancel or something for what
you look so good
let them see you kid underwear is
everything done
here's how i sleep
i love it bobby i like your new hair too
still has all the sleep markings you're
you caught us in a banana break we're
still good are you bananas yeah you have
less nipple hair than all of us except
trisha
i shaved down here too okay
oh no
go get out of here
and then i didn't i didn't shave the um
in between the um the sack and the
thighs so it looks weird melody yeah
it's a little melody you're my favorite
little lesbian can you give me a kiss
how was last night was it good i killed
i bet you [ __ ] did
it's gonna grow bobby it's gonna grow i
killed everyone wearing it in the room
i killed for seven minutes the beginning
seven or the last seven i didn't do 15.
oh you just got off good for you seven
and i just said that's good good and
then everyone was like
[Laughter]
yeah just do whatever you want i'll do
seven i do seventy sometimes because i
just do twenty or three yeah right so if
you do seven it'll just say [ __ ] faces
probably like cute like
like sometimes do that no bye babe
she liked it
it was like an expose
is he on camera this is what i love
about bobby he didn't want to come in
but once we got him
okay
have fun bye bobby
there should be
like not his job
is there a red bull in there there
should be there isn't that's the
funniest interaction i've ever heard in
my life is that how he sleeps yeah that
is so in my in my panties yeah those are
yours we share we share underwear
i love it what is that i got one in my
bag i always carry one in my bag oh it's
nice
you guys don't share underwear with your
are you crazy
no i cannot know i cannot fit into his
underwear
um
we share clothes
all of our from head to toe socks
everything we share everything it's
perfect because um he wears everything
under his socks you stick your toes
through them
she was wearing last time were rough
well he wears everything under his belly
so um he actually fits he buys um pants
sized to me
and we share
yeah he's skinny he's so skinny it's so
weird how i i've always said this too i
feel like everyone looks better naked i
really do i think that's it i feel like
me i look better nick i don't look as
like fat naked i don't know clothes can
bulk you up if you don't want a dress
yeah more people should just be naked he
looks so skinny i was like oh my gosh so
i went because he always calls himself
like well like a meatball or something
i'm like oh he's like tiny he's like a
spaghetti noodle
it's so cute wait i want to ask a
question before we reset
do your parents have your parents
adopted the nickname for you go go queen
no but if you want to actually go there
and have me tell you what happened with
my parents
but we may need to cut this out but i
can't actually keep it in any longer
so i was on a morning walk with my mom
and dad the first day got to their house
and my dad goes wow kalila sure loves
ass licking
by the way you might think that's the
bad part that's that's the part that
didn't even bother me
kyla sherlo's ass licking and my mom
goes
wait a second
what skull [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh
she goes oh i just realized what it is
that's what your dad does to me yes mary
oh my god mary
good for you girl just hang back do you
want to tell al you've done enough you
do the dishes mary you do the dishes and
your time is off the trauma
the actual
sexual trauma that i am living with i
like when you said sexual trauma i just
imagined a saxophone yeah and then they
brought it up again later at dinner
because it because guess what [ __ ]
holiday it was this past weekend dia de
los muertos my birthday so there's
skulls everywhere for day of the dead at
the mexican restaurant did your dad just
go up and [ __ ] all of them and my dad
just goes
he wants to have schools and my mom's
like
and i finally it got really serious and
i was like hey
mom do you want to picture your mom and
dad [ __ ] doing that and she's like oh
okay so that's what i'm dealing with
thanks to this hit show
i think that we should as a team or as
girls reclaim skull [ __ ] because it's
always been something that dudes have
you know bragged about doing to girls
and i think what they don't realize is
like we're lazy yeah we wouldn't we
don't want our neck to go back and forth
so we just take it and the jokes on [ __ ]
the jokes on that a million percent i
also will say i like the word face [ __ ]
a little better maybe because my parents
ruined skull [ __ ] for me but like
i
100 actually think that you have started
here on this show a feminist movement
that's pro
face [ __ ]
and i i i texted george i want to make
shirts that say either i want to skull
[ __ ] me i'm a slug or like face [ __ ] me
i'm a feminist
because i feel like we are creating
the positive facebook
manifesting that all you women out there
just lean back and open up okay no neck
movement ladies dude it's 20 20 years
look you can't you can't if you're a
slug we don't do neck movement we don't
have necks we just lay back and take it
and they think they're doing something
to us but it's really we're winning yeah
we're not doing any work no calories
burned during [ __ ] anymore this is
iconic
apparently my mom and stepdad still are
very active and
that knowledge was that information was
dropped on me about two weeks ago excuse
me
please tell me more well you know my
mom's a [ __ ] cyborg right yeah so we
know that she probably like can hardcore
[ __ ] still
but i'm really surprised my stepdad's
like well into his seventies and he's
you know he's on a lot of meds and
apparently he still likes to [ __ ] my
parents haven't [ __ ] since
like one yeah my parents would always
make jokes about it and i'm like okay
literally i'm just i'm jealous i've
never been more jealous
well
yeah because you don't they love each
other they're best friends now maybe
they [ __ ] i don't know there was one
actually there was one valentine's day
that's true they also might be really
good at keeping it when i was leaving
when i was when i was living at home and
i didn't have any friends my parents
were like
uh do you mind it was their anniversary
or something like can you like go out
like and i was like i literally can't i
have no friends i had no one to go hang
out with been there and i just heard
like
oh slow and slow and deep well they got
to make it last they only do it once a
decade slow fucking's good i like that
slow fast how did you feel about it both
you gotta have slow yes low first yeah
did it mess you up it was gross but i
was happy for them
did you does it mess you up to know that
your mom is [ __ ] your stepdad because
i have a theory because it doesn't gross
my sister out as much as it does to me
because my dad is her stepdad so i'm
like is it easier if it should be worse
it should be worse
her mom's getting plowed by some strange
man
my mom does the plowing in this one so i
don't feel as bad as your mom whip eggs
or step dad thank you guys you guys call
her up call her up
my mom i mean it's weird because they're
both control freaks so like i don't know
how that works who takes charge i feel
like you do you come in and you're like
listen
i i i'm taking control of this one you
are on the bottom today you're on the
top i would love for you to do that for
me and dave but just um choreograph
something for us to do yeah i'd love to
[Laughter]
made it too easy yet again
you really are just it's like i feel
like i'm about the batting cages it's
like really slow
my life is so easy when i'm around it's
like people think i'm like a comedic
genius because you're such a [ __ ]
ding-dong
you're such a lay-up i it's like the
easiest moments i literally were getting
in the car i was like let's go do our
hit podcast that is the easiest thing in
the world to do
[Laughter]
it's you are a sl it is because you're a
slug
my dad literally this weekend said to me
he's like your to me esther your comedic
strength is that you make other people
funnier yeah you really do
thanks dad
somebody told me once that you like your
[ __ ] oh my god
wait where's the shame in that i do too
no but like she's the only guy who holds
no no
[Music]
let me just say this let's go back to a
restaurant restaurant analogy okay
if i eat an average hot dog at a hot dog
stand right
i'm gonna be like i'm not gonna tell
anybody about it right
the only way i could tell somebody to go
to this hot dog stand is if this hot dog
was the best hot dog i've ever eaten
that's how people explain eating her ass
oh no i feel like that's the title of my
biopic yeah yeah why eating an average
hot dog for eight years
that's my final pick your favorite [ __ ]
you
you're right yeah
why won't he eat your ass um he's just
that's just not she's a hot girl that's
like i know even if i were to spread it
even if it was nicely soaked and
scrubbed oh really last night you know
okay
this is what i did last night you know
that machine
the massage machine that you guys got
yeah yeah you all got one yeah right she
goes dude this on my leg all right so i
go she had her legs out and her
underwear so she's kind of you know i
really wanted a massage i know i'm using
the machine right but while i'm doing it
i'm
no but see he wasn't even kissing my leg
like gina darling said he was kissing
the bed no i was kissing your ass you
were you weren't you were like kissing
the sheets no i was kissing your ass and
you're like you know i was kissing your
ass and you're like that that's i don't
want that right now i was i'm sore i
need a real massage there's a time for
that but see
you're not being very truthful
oftentimes you do bop and wet willy but
last night i didn't and don't anyway
esther so you're what's a signal that
you give your partner what's the correct
way to signal your what to signal a
partner just speak in general
that sex is impending that something is
gonna is about to happen
like texts like hey you want to have sex
meet in the bedroom
oh that's good could i ask you about
your [ __ ] yes so you are
you are obsessed with this whole
narrative for years you've brought this
up
furry because
for years you bring up this narrative
that you are just attached to by just so
tightly that yes guys in the past have
have been drawn towards eating my ass
the guys i've dated i i moved down here
to la
[Music]
i was fresh from skokie illinois nobody
had ever even tried to do that so i was
very surprised when i started dating and
guys just went straight for it and i was
like wow like why yeah it was very new
to me it was exotic and then it just
became something like it was like a
talking point like wow
no it was explained to me i'm sorry i
like that okay shame again shame on that
person for details it's not just one
person no i want to hear this several
people
i'm angry for you i know i know several
people all right if it was just one i
would just let it go as hearsay okay
okay
all right
she she threatens litigation by the way
yeah i would be and i'm not naming names
so that so there's no legal matter here
okay but several folks
said
that i know bobby
you don't like eating ass
i go i don't like it
they go but that you would and i'm like
that always struck me they did not say
yes yeah so that's what they did that
always struck me as a mythical asset
what does your [ __ ] look like so
that's what
for me it's always been what's down
there
msg msg
i want to know yeah yeah is it a
different color or flavor what is it
it's just somebody was hyped on me and
they were just bragging about me and
yeah that's what it was that is a crazy
thing to say yeah i'd be proud of it
yeah all buttholes are the same
apparently not they're not apparently
not turns out there are levels to this
game there's levels of i think we should
crash jules's prom tonight and to have a
redo and i think we should dance our
little hearts out
that's my first prom and it would be
annie's first prom we could take
pictures we didn't have a special why is
george laughing like this was already
planned and that i'm being sprung
what oh my god you're so paranoid it's
so funny is this like a
what's going on is this real
i think that we should
drop drop some 50s down chaperone
and just tear it up you're all looking
at me like you're freaking out knew this
was coming and like
if i did this esther jules would never
speak to me again and also let's be real
it would be like pig's blood from carrie
without you would [ __ ] kill us
by the way my dream is for pigs blood to
fall on you and i know it would be the
worst thing that ever happened to you
but i just want you to know there's a
dream in my heart that is inappropriate
to say here comes jules with her dress
come on in jules oh my god
cute are you upset they stole your thing
where did you get it
the music it's retrofets that's this was
gorgeous
the brand oh my god you have a boyfriend
oh you're going to leave you're so hot
this is so hot now you're definitely
going to beat up esther
oh my god jules that's what you're
saying i feel like an old lady like i'm
like oh my god look at the prettiest you
want to like pinch your cheek because
you know wait hang on a second so jules
you don't have a date right that was a
choice yes
yeah we tried to offer her some date
potentials and she was like no i'm who
like christy stefano
really honest or chris let's settle it
[Laughter]
um and so what advice would you give to
a shy girl going to prom
in terms of like how you get in on the
dance floor
you i think you just do whatever like or
just own what you're doing you're going
by yourself you don't have a date like
you look great just own that because the
only thing that matters is you being
confident so just dance by yourself
mm-hmm she's getting so uncomfortable
dancing like no one's watching jules
also on stand like no one's
that's it you the way you stand the way
you're very like this is not going to
catch you a dick girl so you got to
stand it will but it's not it's going to
be someone that's like i can take
advantage of her yeah it's not going to
be the dick you want shoulders up
shoulders up
[Laughter]
um you don't know this but we've all
paid our 50 dollars to be your
chaperones tonight
[Laughter]
so we'll just we're just going to tear
it up on the dance floor guess who's
going to be in the pictures with you
and that's your date
jules you look so stunning in this dress
i knew you would love it i was gonna say
it back to you
you look so stunted
it's so big it looks great did you try a
bunch on did you know that's right off
online she was like that's that was the
one
and it just fit her body
19.
oh my god
all right jules well thank you for your
time we'll see you tonight on the dance
floor
oh my god she's so upset with you
do you have a thong i see your panty
line
no
wear whatever underwear you want don't
listen to this grim groomer what do you
think she should do with her hair um
wavy or pin like sleek down
oh
sleek i think i feel like the wavy
though goes with the dress more
it's kind of like
free spirit i feel like nine for
ninety's sake it would be sleek with
like barrettes and it would
clash with the stuff oh with this with
this yeah with a little so she really
has prom there's really problems
and they all got all the kids got tested
or show their vax cars oh my god i've
thought you meant sexual asses stds i
was like they're being this open about
it they can just go [ __ ] freely i'm like
this is so unfair we had to go to
bathrooms can i just say you look so hot
this is crazy
i do yes the oh i'm sad i missed the
fake modesty over there
i have
starting to get frustrating i'm going to
start slapping you around wait hang on
do you guys want to whip your ass until
you're ready it makes sense she you know
if she had better self-esteem she would
be with a hotter dude yeah well how do
you feel about your model fiancee by the
way congratulations yeah well i mean
it's all about i think women know y'all
know how to
look at other things yeah you know what
i mean this was the fake fight we got on
i'm so sorry about that can i apologize
dears later
no no it was fine when we had to fight i
thought we squashed it until i'm looking
at this clip that people sent me from
this [ __ ] pocket oh i love that well
you guys are just first of all heard
just going like can i tell you something
eric griffin said to me like like just
like just out of nowhere i said you know
what you should wear lingerie that's not
what the [ __ ] happened and what did i do
on monday i understand but that's what i
love
oh that's so funny it didn't help all
and then she says it and then this one
jumps in oh well let me tell you and
then you even said this i don't even
remember what it was about and then you
just you know i was like
thank god esther was just like i'm just
going to be quiet
this is going to go well let's just say
esther doesn't dip her toe in the pool
okay
yeah she didn't even want to show up
swim let's just say that i wanted you
guys i wanted to show you not only do i
have yeah you want to say consent yeah
consent hit their pasties they look
great you're so lucky that could really
have been a mangled mess
because she had boob jobs then she got
rid of the boobs he knows he was there
the day after i took my titties out i
was trying to look i'm trying to see it
no i mean i get it you're like no
medically i would like to say i'm
curious
but it's like it's like you know
look as a dude we have a such a stupid
perspective on breast surgery you know
and i it changed
talking to a friend of mine one time and
she rocked my world with how she said it
because it's like you know uh she got a
she had big titties that were fake you
know and she said i got rid of them
because i was just tired of the
attention now a guy perspective means
what do you mean you're tired of the
attention that's why you got him you
want to have big you know and then she
said to me she was like no i just wanted
to i wanted to feel like a woman i
wanted to wear dresses a certain way i
wanted to you know i just you know you
know and i was like
oh
they do look so good in shirts like i do
love a couple
on me
they did it on me it made me look like
what just turned you into a different
thing and if you have the self-esteem
you have right
it doesn't you're you're good you've
worked on it though so it's like you can
take a compliment but people that have
like true low self-esteem when someone
calls them hot it like almost hurts them
because it's like that's not how i feel
yeah i think that's mostly what you nail
you you actually nailed it right there
we all feel that i feel great you guys
can compliment me all you want i know
i'm amazing it's it took a while to get
here but
why are you looking at me like that i'm
drinking you in
drinking yen
show is in hawaii coming back glowing do
i look pregnant again no you look great
i don't you didn't look pregnant last
time you looked like you had gotten
fillers or something or botox
and from hawaii you mean yes so the tan
will do but my tan is faded so the
fillers the botox look is gone i hold
this by the way because my hands sweat a
lot so if you receive that and it annoys
you trust me this is a coping mechanism
we've been through this yeah i know i
just need to remind you but i want
everyone to know that she has a whole
that's i'm convinced
all of your like ailments are things
that just make you hotter to men because
like you have sweaty hands so it's like
a hand job
like it's true you said that you can't
grow your vagina hair
yeah
that is true
god is just gifting me all of these but
that ass hair really does grow the ass
hair is a problem it's frowing out you
know what i hate to tell you guys but
that's coming that's
the growth has stopped there too
well i manscaped
i do a light manscaping and then i kind
of just let's be honest there's nothing
light about your mansion
the light the led light
i did a medical grid
i manscape but it's not it's very sloppy
guys do have
power when they make you feel a little
like they could leave you at any point
like the fact that i know todd will be
with me until my last breath i really do
very little for him
it is true they got to keep you kind of
thirsty yeah he needs to flirt with
someone in front of me he never he's so
he's such a good boy i'm like you got to
do something why is that i god that is a
terrible thing about me what is that
when i'm shown like total love and
devotion it's um
it's almost like i don't know what to do
with it because it's not what i'm
familiar with like my mom kept me
thirsty for her love i'm still thirsty
for her
you know um
like some validation from her so it's
like those are the types of relationship
i had growing up so it's the same ones
that i have with men so
my ex was
probably the greatest guy you could ever
meet i just could not get there yeah and
because i was young and stupid maybe now
okay let's try it let's bring it back on
but why are you down why does it work
with bobby but it didn't work with the x
because it keeps me so thirsty he gives
me no love and affection i'm just always
like can you just touch my hair today
faster when i see the way you look and
then i see that giant sparkler on your
finger what do you mean because you look
like such a little my little baby like a
little kid oh you're my little baby
that's
engaged we're both engaged is your
engagement real or fake mind's face
mine's fake
i mean what is engagement it's a fake
made-up thing anyway like are you
actually gonna get married yeah yeah
today i hit up the jeweler that bobby
flaked on
and i was like so what's the deal is he
has he paid you
and he was like i don't think i'm
supposed to say anything you know like
don't
um but i strong-armed him into giving me
an answer
so and has he paid
so he wants to marry you but he's broke
right now well he i think that he just
doesn't know how to do anything
yeah he he's it's so he's not broke but
the best confused the best example of
bobby is that
when he was younger his
car
had like too many tickets or no he
couldn't find his car so he just bought
a new car
right
or let's suppose a flat tire
god forbid you call triple a no you just
buy a new one
you just leave it
i'm a handler yeah
i'm a [ __ ] zookeeper
yeah that's what i am that's an animal
trainer and then you add annie and me
into the mix you're a full-blown
zookeeper
[Laughter]
that's wow
shout out by the way nicholas potash so
he makes these amazing like not um
standard
um jewelry and i was really excited
because he was a fan of the show
and he was like hey let me make your
engagement ring
and
i went on bobby's dms
because bobby's like you do it you set
it up oh my god he makes you do
everything yeah he made me set up my own
um he was like tell him exactly
yeah not a finger was lifted on his end
does he not have like a buddy who you
could at least pretend i'm his buddy
yeah wait isn't it so is it happening is
he getting it's not it's not happening
us there yes
now i know i'm gonna have to come out of
pocket for my own ring
oh britney spears style
i think she did that with k yeah with k
fed she wait how much should k fed
really
make at that time
not a lot if you use a backup dancer
like that then those
opportunities are not like consistent
these jeans were ripped naturally i've
had them since i was 15 years old that's
such a funny thing to bring up i'm so
jealous because i [ __ ] read a
magazine article once it said halle
berry kept a g pair of jeans since she
was 15 so she could always know that she
fit into them so then i was i read that
when i was 15 i was like i'm going to
save this pair of jeans but now i can't
find them so it's like my goal i have to
find they're a toddler too
i can't oh my god i want you guys to
actually wear these jeans because they
are so soft but so fragile at this point
like any movement it's so sad though for
me like by the way i would bust them and
then all of a sudden the leg would be
flapping open
and also when someone jeans are baggy on
one person and then the other person
puts them on and it's like well i guess
these pants aren't traveling sisters
oh boy
but the best is when a rip jean has like
a secretly sexy rip like how you have so
you can kind of see your underwear like
do you know the ones where it's like
right under the butt cheeks i have a
couple of those that to me to me is
sexier than lingerie how do you well
let's be real lingerie has that ever
been in your life that was so weird it's
too much too big of a swing do you guys
wear laundry
do you can't even wear
laundry laundry
she's in my mouth
my mom calls it lingerie oh it's so cute
darling maybe you should try to impress
bobby with some lingerie i love that
even your mom's like listen you've let
yourself go oh you're going to lose this
you're going to lose this no and you
know eric griffin once told me something
that i'll never forget and it pissed me
off to no end which is um maybe you
should walk around the house in more
lacy things
[Applause]
eric griffin notoriously says the most
triggering annoying things like a man
could say
i once we did a pilot for a show where
we were gonna like be uber drivers that
were sent taking people to like go get
their
boyfriends back because i was like so it
was this idea that eric's like this is
gonna sell and i'm like i don't even
know what the idea is it makes sense
that you and eric were cast as uber
driver
and also when do you have two uber
drivers
that's how bad we are we needed a helper
but but we were like you know how to do
these like fake tests or like pretending
to drive and i can't tell you how many
times i was
genuinely screaming at him like eric
because he was like women are so shallow
i'm like my boyfriend is 350 pounds i'm
shallow
it was so annoying i do like meanwhile
he has like a model girlfriend i'm like
oh worship i think that's what happened
i think he looked at his his own model s
perfect looking girlfriend and then
looked at me and he probably thought
bobby's my best friend you could
probably try a little bit harder i think
he was trying to help bobby out but
bobby well he doesn't know that bobby
doesn't like that no it's weird
that's a specific guy like yeah yeah
lingerie is like hard because i i feel
like i the way i picture it is never the
way i look in it and it's so traumatic
when you see yourself and like though so
if they're super it's just lingerie in
your size is literally pedophilic i mean
that's like
they don't have come in children's sizes
i like the idea that like the garter
like comes up to here on you
i have a i have a
proposition you put the crap the
crutches part over your head
i have a proposition i think that we
should work through our lingerie trauma
and we should have a lingerie episode
okay okay so we bring our fav well we
bring what we would never wear a type of
lingerie that we would never wear in the
bedroom do we get it for each other no
no no
you will bring me like titles
vaginalists
can i can we also do
a bathing suit day because i have real
bathing suit trauma right can we do like
a bathing suit after can i get like 12
weeks no before that no we don't get to
just spring it on i think that's the
point yeah we just spring it off and we
love the body work yes we'll spring it
on with a side bush everything you know
what i will recommend which i would do
is like hi
i don't need any recommendations from
you high waist
high waist high waist you know does not
look good on me at all oh my god
i promise you the barbie doll because it
no because you know how just like it
covers my like sick hard ass yeah it's
not good for me it's not it makes me
look even boxier than i am
because if you know the the trend of
like the really high cut bikini yeah and
but it's kind of low in the front i will
show you guys i will prove it to you
that it's not my best look i look better
with low lower writing even though i
hate low ride stuff
my body looks better in lower right i
look elongated right like you don't yeah
i would kill to look better in low
riding like i would have you look cute
in low riding
you have like you know what you have you
have like the belly like remember when
britney spear this is again creepy but
this was the world when she did the
first like hit me baby one more time and
she had like the little bit of a belly
yeah you have like that thank you i i
have a little more but i will take the
compliment graciously i mean you are
wearing this high but you also had to
fold it over your confusing specimen
thank you she it doesn't quite fit but
then it also is too big we're talking
about the skirt
they've figured it out okay
should we take a banana break
[Music]
so instead of uh we're having a banana
break what what what special item do you
have for us today george
instead of baking today uh i have found
the haunted ghost pepper pockies
oh my god i've heard real heat
i've heard of ghost peppers what do we
have after it uh liquid death water
where no [ __ ] you don't give us
a uh
you gotta have the out like i'll tell
you what we'll have after it bloody
[ __ ]
we'll have
okay
esther we you got to use the thing again
so we can use your squirtle to oh my god
you you have to admit that that thing
made you have to pee right
no you know what it did i already had to
pee and it made it that i could no
longer deny it
so what i said
okay i am going to try these but only
because the packaging is cute they
actually really good oh she hasn't
swallowed yet
and they look like doritos
oh my god we have nothing to cure it oh
my god oh my god oh my god that is a
producer oh my god job
to have some milk or yogurt
oh my god oh my god banana banana just
enjoy it addy oh now that's a good
remedy
oh my god give me the banana george
you want this banana
oh
so gross george george is like the only
cure is my ginger dick wait whoa
you want this banana i'm so confused
because it doesn't why is it taking this
long to make that i do love chips but it
is so
it's i'm okay
but i think what i know of this is that
it gets worse it hit me instantly
the problem is i like chips
that's what i'm saying is i want to eat
them i think
my hunger for chips is overriding the
pain it is going down my body george do
you have any mild chicks it's at my
nipples now do you want to put the stuff
up my butt now
do i
with these spicy chip hands
well my butt needs it now after these
chips i'm four bites into my banana and
i'm still on fire go ahead and say this
combo
quite something you're still going
yeah
cause we're fatties
we love good [ __ ] i have to conquer my
fears
oh my god i'm still on fire
it's pretty hot george why don't you
have a chip
um i don't have a like a camera close-up
on me no that's the problem i didn't uh
the banana's not helping it
it's not it's not it's cold for a second
it's like it's like
it's not a carrot
one time bobby is having really bad
diary at 7-eleven i was like eat a
banana can i tell you i'm trying to like
be just proud that you're eating bananas
now and not livid
wait what you didn't want to eat them
for so long and now
i
you had to come to jesus banana i don't
really like bananas but my parents
convinced me that they're really good
for you and you might as well just eat
them but i definitely cannot eat a whole
banana yeah the consistency issues with
them or the taste no it's just like
it's just not that good so i'm like it's
not really worth my
my ingested calories well packaged it's
such a good snack but do you um do you
like banana flavored like laffy taffy no
no one does look at george look at
george look at george turn red oh no
oh my god his neck is red
where's the milk george
george do you have any chips that are
not spicy i would probably pay a
thousand dollars for one
um
i don't think so but we'll see
it's survivable like i could eat a whole
bag if i had to if there was money
involved yeah
it just made me want chips
oh i bet my lips are gonna get puffy
oh what a gift
oh i forgot about cheetos i haven't had
them since i've tried that
[ __ ] ginger
oh like a black okay jordan oh yeah oh
yeah i forgot do you consider yourself a
ginger no blonde no i'm blonde okay
that's the gingerous ginger
is that the ginger it's the white walker
it's the white walker of gingers are
asians allowed to say ginger
we use it i like gingers i've banged a
bunch of gingers i'm fans of ginger so
that's why i think i can make fun
sexually aggressive the ones i've been
with in a good way i am not a ginger for
people who think she's hinting at me
my yeah my mouth
my lips my tongue
there's tingles you're [ __ ]
what is that bean boozled okay here's
here's what i think we should just do is
everyone gets a packet and we just eat
them and then you just tell me what you
think you're experiencing
and you said everybody i'll play too oh
my god well let's get it
it is candy
extra flavor so okay
well the smells are a little
basically what this is is you eat a
flavor and like let's say i have a blue
one and i have to eat it and it's either
going to taste like berry blue or like
toothpaste you have a blue one yeah this
is not that bad what color do you have
i'll tell you which one are you gonna
eat well tell me what my options are
here why don't you eat burger king eat
the green one so the green one is either
juicy pear or booger
uh oh it's it's booger it's grass it's
booger it's not what color did you do
booger
[Laughter]
dude i'm gonna do white
oh wait no
wait white is either coconut or spoiled
milk okay the one you have to do
please do the one that's strawberry
banana strawberry banana or dead fish
that's strawberry oh
i'm so mad i really wanted
what's the white one give me give me
what's a white one white one is or is
coconut or spoiled milk i got a tone
okay i'm gonna do blue and coconut
toothpaste toothache isn't bad
but it's not good candy that's such a
like ester bad one
i never brushed my teeth it tastes like
something i put in my mouth every day
oh my god
[Laughter]
what is that
what another toothpaste
i think that's a spoiled milk one is i
need to have a good one
i know i want a good one these are fun
no not anymore ah fun stops right there
are we signing off for the week that one
tasted actually pretty rotten i don't
like it no it tastes like dead fish but
so did every dead fish fed me on this
show wait that's all we've been eating
every week
out guys so what do you have prepared
for us today oh my god what is it
bryce
this is dangit
i love this stuff what is it it's a
dried fish oh
no i grew up on this [ __ ] it's the best
no
i still scrape your tongue
my family business my not my family
business my uncle's business was making
these was drying up like when you go to
your uncle's house there was just like
dried fish are you gonna eat it annie of
course when am i not it's actually very
good you think that's better worse than
this
definitely not
no what is that shout out to the camera
what is it
ew why is my baby food they should go to
esther
no no no
this is baby food
this is for esther annie don't worry
you're gonna eat what i'm holding this
is absolutely not i know what it is i've
seen these at kids parties when i used
to babysit
it's [ __ ] quick is that because you
weren't you weren't invited when you
were a kid
what
it off my happened
take it off my lap who
dude who is in trouble what am i why did
you bring me these what is it dude it's
[ __ ] full
on crickets oh my god
dude
dude i'll get it i'll get it i'll get it
get it i'll get i'll say the crickets
you're screaming like they're alive dude
oh my god don't look i cannot look at
them they're huge whole crickets
honestly what's in the skirt is scarier
to me
is this just regular baby food or is it
like yeah you got flavored give her
those crickets those are for her this
bryce made a mistake oh my god if this
had like flown up and all of them flung
on esther what a happy accent can i just
say
i don't want any kind of jokes
uh like no one's done anything to you
pranks like i would love to just see you
try the fish and then i want to i do
want to see you eat the crickets though
do you see i just want to see this is
we've summed it up where'd you get these
are these fresh all right so i do want
to say it has an aroma of
oh day s a stem
it does not all day five days this is
this i would be driving you a bath too
i could eat a lot of pineapple okay okay
these are crickets
all right look at it these are salt and
vinegar
are you going to eat it kalaelis yeah
i'm going to try i don't like that it
doesn't just break it's not my first
cricket
that's fine it is kind of gross it does
i feel like you know what they're
usually supposed to be a lot crunchy or
annie
but it's very tasty
maybe hot sauce yeah it's it's they're
not as fresh as i wanted them to be but
if you had real good like blood with
rice oh my gosh i think i could really
wait with rice and what
like fried fish and stuff
well dried fish with a little bit of
vinegar in it
the best here i could see us like
watching tv
and me just
really getting into it would you like a
cricket madam yeah
oh rest in peace literally
sorry that your life was taken for
snacks
are you [ __ ] kidding me
i don't know i don't even eat my bryce
you know i'm vegetarian
have you
i've eaten crickets before yeah but i
haven't had these particular ones now
annie you're really like okay with this
yes you're ready
in one
two three
oh delicious mmm
it's delicious esther peanutty nothing
crickety about it at all peanutty
i actually like the fish better though
but there's no taste even it's just like
a chip
i'm sorry mr cricket should we move on
to i see marshmallows do we have more
treats this week are we trying an esther
delicate delicacy i is is that what it
is
i mean esther's delicacy is such a joke
yeah esther will make it for us what is
weird about this by the way there's
nothing weird it's just called dry
s'mores thank you so much and a lot of
people what they like to do is they sit
by a campfire they melt their
marshmallows and their chocolate and
they like a gushy mushy s'mores but i'm
telling you
dry
raw s'mores just all non-cooked is
delicious you trying to claim s'mores as
your own is
wild right now
so and i want you guys to tell me
or you think if you think like oh no of
course we should roast this instead or
if you kind of like it dry well i'm i'm
kind of i have an aversion to things
that might stab the roof of my mouth and
oh that seems a terrible feeling yeah
you know when you eat chips oh you take
a chip the wrong direction wrong
direction
[Laughter]
what are your expectations um i feel
like i think it's gonna taste exactly
like i know it's gonna taste because
we've all had s'mores before sometimes
they're not they're not really like that
high you know here we go
it's so messy after
no i mean it's good all the ingredients
are delicious i just don't like it i
would like it a little like melty though
i love it this way i think it's so much
better this way the chocolate does taste
better this way
i love it this way
but going from the fish to cricket to
this
made it all the more delicious i have to
say i want to say i had a little
appetizer
that you didn't have well you guys thank
you for listening to this week's
bloodbath
um that was so much sure it's a mukbang
um this show is turning into a
full-blown mukbang every week
um we appreciate you um please go to
itunes and give us five stars six stars
seven stars all the stars we love you
and we'll see you next week
can i ask you a question yeah is your
response always here comes a guy in
whatever setting
and he's clearly
trying to get with you
you entertain this or is there ever
anything in you just to be like
this is not gonna happen
yeah but i'm saying like what um do you
ever do that or if you don't why not
sometimes i do it sometimes i don't
right so sometimes it's like
it's like it depends on what the
situation is like if it's someone who is
like i'm working with you kind of have
to like there's a dance you have to do i
mean it's like guys are always doing
some [ __ ] but it's like i
you ha it's just like you just
be gross she's she's right there's
always a dance and it's like i'm not
gonna [ __ ] me too i'm not gonna be
like this guy is attracted to me or
whatever it's like he's just like
shooting a shot but i let people shoot
their shot once same if they do it again
i i'm like and i've already said no
that's like that's a [ __ ] that's a
problem
and he's 1000 correct it's like
i'm not supposed to assume that he knows
i have a boyfriend he's shooting a shot
right so in that moment i'm polite and i
i take on like whatever advances he's
putting on because i don't he doesn't
know but in that moment where he's like
asking for my number and i'm just like
hey like no thanks like you know i'm not
interested i don't even say i have a
boyfriend actually i'm not interested
yeah only because it's like i'm not
saying no because i have a boyfriend i'm
saying no because it's no well there's
like back in the day
that's a whole different thing because
that makes him feel like if the
boyfriend was out exactly right right
yeah and then sometimes it's like
sometimes you're like maybe i do want to
just give this guy the ego thing and
it's like sorry i'm just like not
available now or whatever you know just
like let them feel fine and then they go
off sometimes yeah and that's like who
knows that's like from whatever my own
[ __ ] is from yeah with my dad my
brothers and guys i dated when i was a
kid well it's it's even in that moment
there like when i was younger i used to
feel codependent where i'm like i don't
want anyone to walk away feeling bad
yeah but like as i've gotten a little
bit like where i am now i'm just like
i'm just too tired to take care of
anyone's feelings anymore
it's better for them too right to know
like to know the truth i mean you should
know what your batting average is you
should learn truth about it
surprisingly i would always prefer i
prefer somebody just being like no thank
you yeah and i'm just like okay cool
boom done well you know a lot of guys
actually take it pretty well exactly
like huh they take it pretty well a lot
of people
that's what i'm trying to say i think
that like
i feel like
you're gonna get the visceral response
that you probably need anyway like it's
all i'm saying like if you go no
and if the guy's like well [ __ ] you then
it's like well i'll say this is what i'm
saying no yeah i just go or a guy's
gonna be like i had a guy so i had a
producer guys
this project i was working on and i
would get like i was going in like not
every time yeah like so i wasn't like a
regular writer on the show and he
[ __ ] leaned in focus and i was so
pissed and i immediately like i was like
no dude so annoying it's just so
annoying it's like you're in like
you are the one that hires me like [ __ ]
you and so i was so annoyed because and
i used to have so much fun with him i
just like hang out with him all the time
and i was like are you serious dude and
then the minute i was single he did that
and then i was like all right shoot your
shot whatever maybe you just like me
and then maybe he obviously liked you
yeah yeah i know it's not always like
but it's just so [ __ ] so annoying
it's like can we do it when the [ __ ]
show's over but um and also can we not
do it i didn't want to do it anyway but
so i was like
like no and then i left and then i
texted him i was like so when am i
coming in the room again like
immediately like
i'm not like forfeiting my [ __ ] job
you know like i'm just like hey remember
we work together and yeah
the other end of that though is there
are moments that annie and i talk about
where it's like it's very clear
someone's coming on to you and you say
no but when i have a girls night out
the rules change a little bit and the
rules change on the dance floor so i
always tell bobby this i call it my it's
called hf which is
heavy flirting but i take no numbers i
take no names i don't even look at their
[ __ ] face hoe form
i thought it was heavy flow oh my god
she's bleeding on them that's great and
so let's say for instance i'm dancing
there's someone behind me and i'm just
dancing i will i will grind up on
whatever dick there is behind me not
even turn around to look at their face
the song is over i walk straight forward
there's no exchange of words there's no
exchange of anything it's just
having a good time which is going on how
many guys
how many guys right now watching this or
like hoping they see her at a at a dance
club like i'd love to get those kalila
blue balls yeah she's like there's
they got sweatpants on with no underwear
i imagine i'm imagining her doing it but
it's square dance
like i don't get to touch their dicks
and square dance collisions or it's a
wedding thing got to the left
thank god to the right it's a [ __ ] um
bobby is so not threatened um by
anything
at all like even when i was like sweetie
please come with me to see an old friend
of mine he's like please please please
don't make me go please don't make me go
and i was like what if like he's into me
he's like i don't give a [ __ ] please
don't make me go yeah yeah i totally get
that energy i don't want to go see you
some guy from high school just gets so
sad yeah it's like why you don't want to
see the life leave the eyes of a man
when you show up with a guy
you know what it is though you know what
we need to work on because i'm actually
getting a lot like these questions
you're asking are interesting because i
think i've done so much work on myself
just in the past like few years that i
would have a completely different
situation well you know what i want to
say about what you were saying earlier
is and what i appreciate about you in
this moment is
especially because
this is layered it's nuanced because
like it's you having a good time with
the guy you work with there is some
chemistry because you're having a good
time all right so
is there a possibility like and it's
like what you're talking about is hey
let's be professional so yeah we're
having this thing let's be professional
so maybe like outside of work if you
want to take a shot cool if i and if i
want to say at that point hey listen i
really enjoy working with you but i
don't want to i'm not romantic with you
like that it is there then it's like on
the other person to be like all right
you know what yeah i'm into you like
that but i think we have a good
it's like okay so louie and his apology
said this and i thought this was
actually so good in his apology he said
when i was asking these girls what i
thought i was doing was asking these
girls a question but what i realized now
is i was presenting them with a
predicament and that's something that i
was like oh that kind of like felt like
rung true where i was like in these
working environments when you are kind
of afraid of that and it's like it is a
comedy room so it's like and we you're
right we do have chemistry but i'm like
dude i'm [ __ ] crushing in this room
right now like do not ruin this thing
because you want to get your dick wet
it's like it's not like he was on one
knee proposing to me it's like he was
trying to [ __ ] me at a party you know
what i mean yeah yeah yeah dude like but
i had a and my ex-boyfriend helped me
with this um because i used to get so
offended when when guys hit on me i went
i thought it meant they didn't think i
was funny
right like i thought it was like you
know all of these like the [ __ ] guys
tell you when you're coming up and
you're doing well like it's just because
you're a girl and i'm like i'm [ __ ]
funnier than you dude like i'm sorry i
was funnier than these [ __ ] guys but
then it gets in your head eventually and
you go wait am i only getting things
because everyone's trying to [ __ ] me you
know and then so i had this thing in my
head where i felt like when guys hit on
me it meant they didn't think i was
funny or respect me and what i realized
is that's not i mean that's just like
from my own past [ __ ] with i get it
molested um but it's like
what what he taught me was he's like no
they could be they're probably just more
attracted to you because they think
you're funny so it's not like so there
is a way to make it there is a way to be
like oh i'm going to take the compliment
of this and just like tell them the
truth and not worry about their feelings
but just like tell them the truth rather
than trying to like maneuver around it
but see i feel like it should be dealt
with i mean i feel like people should
have more open communication about this
i think instead of like denying like i
never was like when i was younger i'd be
the kind of person i'd be like i'd be
like that guy
pretending like i'm your friend and then
a year later i'm like i love you i've
always loved you and it's so [ __ ]
annoying right i know how annoying that
is right so later when i got later when
i was like had more confidence in myself
i would be like nah nah nah nah i'm not
trying to be your friend right yeah
listen
i don't let people dictate the terms of
the relationship to me right i don't get
friend zoned because i'm like nah yeah
i'm trying to get with you you're
getting way blacker no what i'm just
saying
it's uh i'm like we are really we're
coming we're getting i'm just saying it
annoys me when i hear guys talk about
like she's got me in the friend zone no
no you staying in the friend zone it is
totally okay to tell somebody
no because first of all you know what it
is you can't just be my friend
do you know how how
how what it means to build a friendship
you can't just tell me oh we're friends
now no i don't know you like that you
know so no we're trying to i'm trying to
get with you so you deal with that yeah
you have to put it and then if you go
and then so if you say well let's i
don't want to do that the other person
has to have some maturity to be like you
know what this chick's talented i like
how we work together i like what she
does i'll just i just have to deal with
my attraction but i don't say you deny
it yeah the dude's into you because you
were great yeah you know you were funny
and you were attractive and you guys had
good chemistry he just needs to learn
how to deal with working with somebody
you feel that way about it's just like
it does feel like such a like a
trial that when you're like not
expecting it it's the same as the friend
thing like it's like so you've been
friends with this long or we've been
working like it's just like that's what
your intentions were
this whole time it's like oh it's so
annoying
but i'm saying to to go in on that
before i don't want to cut you off but i
just want to because this is great you
can cut me off no no it's just i don't
know so it's just that let's just
quickly i want to quickly explain to
nick okay yeah we're we're a pro face
[ __ ] podcast okay we think it's very
feminist to be at facebook yes i like it
too why are we yeah we don't have to we
don't want to do the work during things
we're
that's exactly i i i was in my special
but i was like i like when a guy grabs
my head and just like does what he wants
to do because i don't want to guess his
rhythm so i like i called it the
birdhouse like he treats my head like a
bird i don't know why like i just feel
like i just have a hole in my head and
he and i like being whole and then when
you're done and then when you're done he
tells everyone i just want to be holes
sorry wait wait literally that's one of
my favorite
statements to say i died
i just want to be like i'm just the role
i want them to be like is this the bed
or my girlfriend like i don't want them
to know the difference between the two i
love just being like i was lis i was uh
reading about like hot things to say in
bed because you kind of run out of
things and i need more and one was use
me like your [ __ ] slave and i was like
that like turned me on for some reason
to just be i want to be used i don't
want to be because sometimes it gets
twisted where i the guy that i'm like
hook up with will maybe sometimes think
that i want to be disrespected i just
want to be as disrespected as you would
treat a hole in the wall like you
wouldn't be like
you're a hole in the wall i want to be
limp like i want you using my body like
i want to be limp and you just move me
around i want to do the least amount yes
andy yes
yes yes yes to all of this i want to be
a come dump yeah i want you to just flip
me over nicki doesn't know i have a i
have one of those hospital beds and i i
zoom up to [ __ ] my boyfriend i zoom up
the bottom i scooch to the edge and i i
press the button and yes and i rise
myself to his penis oh my god i do
nothing it's so hard to do stuff oh god
i don't like to do anything i really do
like to just take it and um i remember
one time my boyfriend at the time uh i
was really tired and he was like horny
and kind of petting on me and stuff and
i go you can but like i'm just gonna lay
i'm not gonna do anything and he goes
as opposed to what like he was like oh
is that gonna be different for us and i
was like you're right like you're such a
good guy that you never make me do
anything like he's
he's really just i i don't ever have to
be on top i just don't want to be on top
i just i'll be on top every once in a
while but it's like it's just sometimes
i'm like oh to see if i miss it and i
don't know yes am i bad am i just bad at
sex
i was you know writing dicks off their
bodies oh wow
i never did that i had a whole yeah i
like to be out of i feel like my whole
life is so in control that most women
that like to be kind of just treated as
an
objectified in bed i they tend to be
like boss [ __ ] in their life and they
just want a little time off like that's
why when i'm in bed i just want to be
holes i don't want to be like have to
think about your pleasure and like think
about you liking me and what i look like
i've spent so much of my life doing that
it's just so much boyfriend the boss
thing my ex boyfriend used to be like
you don't seem into i'm like i'm here
doing it like i don't what do you need
me to be like yay i'm just like enough
we've been dating for two years you know
what annie the more money do a sit-up
too want to get hotter you're ugly
that's true the more money i make the
less work i want to do yes oh wait oh
because money fixes everything so i'm
like why are you throwing money at this
why are you telling everyone about our
sex life
do you want to sit up you're ugly
i've said it to you for years never
listen i just watched this um
french movie called titan that aquafina
suggested that i watched
and um there is a scene there without
giving too much away
where she is
fully having sex with an automobile
right like full on strapped on she's
[ __ ] it she gets pregnant by the
automobile right and i want to ask her
it was actually an old car which made it
even hotter but i want to ask you guys
have you ever had sex with an inanimate
object
no or been attracted to one or saw a
shape and said you know my room
i have like a it's not a sexual
attraction dude but i am able i look at
my roomba like a pet like it has there's
something about it that i'm like oh i
can understand why people have robots
and treat them like it's i feed it and
i'm like
yeah well i call it roomba even though
it's a shark and um
but uh i just i do feel like i could
have because of my like my relationship
with the roomba and like giving it a
personality and really believing that
and even when it gets tangled up in a
cord and like in the morning i'll go to
its dock and i'm like wait where is it
and i have to go looking for it and i
see i go room what were you doing why
don't you leave like a little bread
trail so it comes to you or like just
comes and sucks
this is my this is my image of you i
want you to get a dildo and like glue it
onto the roomba and then right and be
taken around yes
i do think i could be attracted to
a thing like really almost anything
almost anything you know what because
the le this this is something i actually
did say because that's a common thing
you see in my um my strange addiction or
those shows where a woman uh will get
married to the eiffel tower and although
that's phallic so she can she actually
uses
little um the ones that you would buy at
the gift shop she would use them to like
[ __ ] herself even though she's married
to the actual i got um i married on
ecstasy once and we did eiffel tower
that night so i do kind of like
can you please remind those of us who
didn't do drugs in their 20s what it is
to eiffel tower eiffel tower is not
drugs it's uh when you're like no i i
know something and then you high five
each other while you're it's
i think it could be girls honestly we
should be girls
okay while we spit roast this
but i remember
i always thought that i had a type of
guy that i was attracted to like i have
i have a um
there's a bar you have to hit and there
was a guy you're like i also have a
typewriter
that's next for me
there was this guy that i like fell in
love with uh despite myself just like
there was this you know the energy that
people talk about that i was just
looking at him like
i don't there's if you would have showed
me a picture of like i want to set you
up with this guy i would have been like
do you hate me like i would have might i
would have swiped left so hard the
screen would have cracked in this guy
but there was something about the
physical like just the energy between us
and after i was attracted to him and
like truly turned on by everything he
had going on i was like i understand why
women marry ferris wheels or like things
that you could never it was i could
never imagine a woman is closer to what
i'm a guy that i usually am attracted to
looks like than this guy was like that's
why i was like i can date anyone it's
it's not about physical it's about
energy a million percent it's about the
connection with the person how they make
you feel how you make them feel like if
they let you be like a full lesbian on a
podcast
[Music]
you